okay thank you so much rachel and let me
go ahead and get my screen share
and i saw we have somebody who is
uh
in the woods i saw that was the first uh
first comment there so hello to the
woods and i also see we have folks from
all over the world so we're really
excited to uh be here with you today
let me share
my screen here
and this will be interactive so i'm glad
to see that there are so many comments
already
all right
okay so can everyone see my slides we're
good perfect
wonderful
um so today we're gonna kick off and
talk um
about
the trends that we're seeing in in the
data space and specifically related to
the finance industry before we get
started i always like to set a few
um expectations for for these types of
virtual webinars
what we recommend is to find a quiet
place maybe
one where there's not so many kids dogs
cats uh you know what whatever you have
around the house
also ask is rachel mentioned please stay
on yet unless you have a question or
would like to add a comment
please also silence any alerts from your
cell phones and then last but not least
we always encourage participation we do
have some questions throughout this
presentation as rachel mentioned she
will be sharing out the link to slido um
so
we'll have about 20 to 30 minutes of of
dimitri and and myself presenting and
then we really want to turn it over to
you to guide the conversation and make
sure that everybody leaves with
something actionable today so if you
have questions please feel free to ask
them
before uh we dive in just like to set an
introduction for myself and my
co-founder dimitri um i'm the ceo and
co-founder of data society dmitry is the
chief solution architect and co-founder
as well we started data society back in
2014 really with one mission which is to
help professionals use data better
we do that with our custom data science
training programs that we deliver to
large organizations federal agencies
fortune 500 companies with specific
focus in finance as well and then we
also have a solution side of the house
where we build custom software
predictive uh algorithms and also
support digital transformation efforts
so over the past eight years we've seen
a lot
of how data is being implemented in the
finance space so we're bringing in a lot
of our experience today to share that
with you
what you'll walk away with today
examples of how data is used in finance
trends of data uses in the finance
industry as well as steps that you can
take to start integrating data into your
operations because we get that question
a lot and it's really important for us
to um
help other organizations become more
data driven so you'll definitely walk
away with some ideas that you'll start
to
think about how you can use that in your
day-to-day
with that i'm going to turn it over to
dimitri to kick us off
thanks marav
so
uh let me kick off with a case study of
how
we've leveraged um
data for a financial services use case
broadly speaking what we're seeing is
that there's a trend towards using a lot
of
non-traditional data sources in order to
make financial decisions and that is
impacting every aspect of finance from
underwriting to bond trading
so in this case we had the
inter-american development bank who came
to us with the following question
they fund a lot of infrastructure
projects around the world
primarily in developing countries in
latin america
and they wanted to mine
lending agreements
and infrastructure proposals
in order to better evaluate the
riskiness of those projects and of those
funding packages
they said all we have are pdf style
documents that describe the terms of
those loan agreements
can you help us
extract data from them in a standard way
and then help us build a risk model such
that when new organizations apply for
funding grants or loans effectively for
infrastructure projects
we have a better framework for
determining whether or not they're high
risk and therefore what the appropriate
monitoring structures and levers need to
be
so we built a bespoke tool for them
that did exactly that
it connected to a large repository of
um
infrastructure proposals and associated
loan documents
extracted key terms
and then looked at the historical
outcomes of those projects in order to
build a risk model and say here are the
key factors and elements inside those
loan packages and inside the effectively
project plans
that help us forecast what is the likely
outcome is the project going to be over
time over budget what is the likelihood
of success and so on and so forth
as a result we developed an application
that they could pull up
on their desktops and
rerun the workflow to load extract
additional information uh loan
information from documents and then
price subsequent loans
this type of use case of leveraging
natural language processing plus machine
learning in order to arrive at a risk
model
is something that we're seeing happen
with increased frequency across the
financial services space
next slide please
so
broadly speaking the types of use cases
that we're seeing uh emerging across the
board
are generally fall into a handful of
buckets
risk analytics identifying consumer or
borrower behaviors and trends
the mitigation of operational risks
meaning the actual operational risks of
a bank of an insurance company or any
other type of specialty lender
fraud detection and identity validation
and finally payment and transaction
processing those are some of the biggest
buckets
um fraud has been an
increasingly growing problem
across the world to the point where
there are in fact
actual
fraud factories that have been developed
in some countries like north korea and
russia that will literally build up the
credit histories of a virtual identity
start to borrow money
through so they will still steal some
identity information right you all
probably have heard of the
hack of the office of personnel
management in the united states right so
they'll steal information uh sometimes
they'll buy it on the dark web and
they'll start to literally build up a
credit history for somebody
um over the course of years they develop
a large borrowing capacity
and then when they quote unquote farm
the account they will you know borrow
that sort of large target amount that
they had and then that is when the fraud
actually occurs
and so that type of uh corporatized
systemic fraud is a growing problem and
banks and financial regulators are
continuously looking for solutions to
combat threats that are not necessarily
imminent but equally are large and
systemic
um in terms of identifying consumer
consumer
behavior
there is a big push towards
towards
identifying non-traditional sources of
information about population movement
and population behavior so
what happened was in the pandemic people
stopped showing up to places in person
right this this virtual uh virtual
presentation is a case in point
and so banks started to ask themselves
the question of
do we need physical branches and if so
how many and where
and so we've seen use cases where banks
are pulling cell phone data to start to
understand the new behaviors and
patterns of physical movement
just supposing that with their general
ledger to understand how
the local bank locations are being
utilized and whether or not there's
enough transaction volume to justify
actually having a branch open whether
it's from a deposit growth standpoint or
a loan growth standpoint
and so on the one hand they're investing
in digital applications to do that
making sure that in cyberspace they're
able to avoid fraud
while reassessing their on-prem their
their physical real estate portfolio
um i'll skip operational risk for now
there's a case study i'll touch on a bit
later
um we talked about fraud and finally
there's payment and transaction
processing so there's a variety of
technology products that are
increasingly used to transfer value
right we've all heard of
cryptocurrencies and the latest trend in
non-fungible tokens which is basically
pieces of code that serve as a proof of
record that somebody indeed created
something and somebody else owns it
what's interesting about the utilization
of technology as a proof as an evidence
of something occurring
is that if you think about the nature of
markets it's all about supply and demand
and whereas a constricted supply and in
excess demand you start to have price
growth
in fact the largest
uh the best performing asset class over
the past 30 years has actually been fine
art paintings effectively right so it's
a constrained supply you're not going to
get any more impressionist impressionist
paintings and you're looking at prices
of works skyrocketed from two to twenty
million over the past over the past uh
couple of decades
and so the the ability for technology to
serve as a proof of record that
something indeed happened is opening up
spaces for
artists and other creative use cases to
actually leverage technology and then
finance to actually grow and create
value that's a fascinating trend that's
poised to remake a lot of financial
financial space next slide please
and so what that's fueled is a huge
growth and influx of venture capital so
in fact last year was a record year in
terms of venture capital invested
generally and most of it going
especially into financial technology so
you see this uh semi what is i think
quarterly quarterly data where there was
a huge spike in 2021 it kind of
continued towards towards the end of the
year
so
you're seeing a lot of investors who
have identified this this trend and are
saying how can we
um
how can we create entirely new markets
that uh unlock sources of value that
were previously closed
so if you're in the investment community
there's a lot of money being thrown at
the sector or whether you're looking to
start a company you actually arguably
have the best chance of being funded if
you're in the financial technology
technology space
next slide please
so this huge
well of opportunity
and this huge influx of money
is creating a lot of um a lot of
opening
for
skills and demand for skills so in fact
the in 2021 the largest attic and
technical scale demand is for r and
python programmers in finance
and that
demand right now is hard to fill so
you've had immediate price appreciation
for labor of 10 to 20 for people who are
in finance and have these types of
programming skills
so the skill requirements kind of go up
and down the chain so if you're thinking
about what does it take to actually have
a technology application function
there's the
mechanic of collecting information
storing information
uh changing its shape analyzing it and
presenting it right and there's a
discrete set of technical skills that
are necessary to power it so skill
requirements include knowledge of
databases certainly cloud databases
knowledge of data structures
and an understanding of how to find
patterns and detect statistical
statistical significance
so in fact when we started data society
back in 2014
i myself came from the financial
services side so i started my career as
a as an investment banker
of all things and then i worked at a
quantitative hedge fund for a while
and so what we did is build complicated
um
what now you would call machine learning
basically forecasting models around a
variety of financial portfolios whether
it was portfolios of loans or energy
portfolios or royalties of
pharmaceutical products
and so
we
refined the quality of our analyses and
placed a lot of bets using sort of
analytical methods that at the time were
not standard at a lot of the a lot of
the funds uh in the financial services
space today there's been a broad
recognition that the some of those
analyses are no longer appropriate to do
in excel right you want to use proper
statistical software to do that hence
the huge uptick in our python
and there's an explosion of both
proprietary and open source tools uh
that are available to you guys so
there's a link
uh on this slide for a cranar uh
foreground repository
of over 160 different packages for the
financial services
industry uh i've used a lot of them you
know they're
um they're really powerful as long as
you understand exactly what they're
doing and why they're doing it i highly
encourage you to get you guys to have a
look and what i've learned is because
the power is in automation and just
higher quality prediction
they can really help you move the needle
professionally again whether you're
starting a new company and going after
some of that venture capital funding or
looking to boost your income and looking
for a job where
manual processes of the past are being
increasingly digitized
next slide please
so
one of
the um sort of
emblematic displays
of how data is changing the financial
services space is what the federal
deposit insurance corporation so
effectively the government quasi
government organization that is tasked
with ensuring the deposits of uh savings
uh savings and loans organizations
across the united states
so if you look if you go to their
website uh that talks about tech sprints
that they champion so it's here on the
slide for you you'll read about several
text frames that they've deployed over
the past few years and you'll notice
that they're all about leveraging
technology to address pressing banking
problems
there are cases where they've
asked the community to identify
ways of help the underbanked right so
there's roughly seven million people in
the united states that are towards the
bottom of the sort of uh income um
income demographic
who are under banked uh and need
additional financial services um
that they don't have access to so
they've asked the community how can we
reach these people more effectively
again think back to identifying um
validating
um identity in digital space and then
using technology to facilitate payments
right which is effectively what those
folks need an ability to verify who they
are without a physical access to a bank
the ability to share their financial
information make sure that this is not
fraudulent
and then for banks to actually
facilitate payments for these for these
individuals
there are sprints where they've asked
the community
how to in fact validate those identities
and finally one we participated for
which we developed um a risk framework
that is based on something called camels
camels is a standard um
risk measurement framework for banks
that the fdic uses when they evaluate
banks for their soundness
the sprint for the fdic tasks
participants to think through how data
can be used to alleviate operational
risk so what happens if somebody doesn't
show up to work what happens if the bank
gets hacked does the funding does do the
funds of the clients of the depositors
remain intact do loans get evaporated
and so we designed a framework that
leverages operational metrics such as
the bank's data systems their ability to
um defend against a cyber attack their
redund data redundancy that protects
against key personnel departing so
we create a framework framework and a
technological foundation to do that
now to enhance the framework what we
also showed is
is how to develop a quantitative model
to leverage data that's not
traditionally used by regulators by
banks themselves to look at their
business
so i know this font is a little small so
we can probably distribute this
presentation afterwards but
we actually built a quantitative
framework for leveraging things like um
census data that provides monthly
updates on local economic conditions
local commodity prices so for example um
a lot of uh small to medium sized banks
have well a regional coverage right and
for a lot of them they have heavy
exposure to agriculture so when there is
a precipitous drop in a particular crop
localized to a certain area the entire
portfolio of the bank may be at risk and
yet commodity prices are not a
traditional metric that are used to
evaluate the health of banks certainly
not by regulators so we assembled a
technological architecture using google
cloud
and showed how to input data sources
from commodity markets from the u.s
census from social media from digital
media
all in order to create a more
encompassing framework that helps
evaluate a bank's risk
not just from a financial perspective
but also from from an operational one
so these are all some of the key things
that are changing the mechanic by which
the finance industry works increasingly
connecting it digitally and creating a
much more automated way for managers and
regulators to understand the landscape
of
money slide please
so we warned you that this would be
interactive and we are making good on
our promise so based on you know all the
information that dimitri shared the fact
that we're starting to be able to
combine different types of data sources
that finance hasn't really leveraged
before
one of the questions that we have for
you feel free to answer this in the chat
is the types of data that you're using
today because throughout this
presentation we're gonna
transition
a little bit more broadly about
um
how you can start to think about what it
means to be a data-driven organization
and why that's important
but before we get started i'd love to
hear from you uh if you use
data what does that look like
um are any of you using social media
data
i see
we have someone that's using transaction
data card payments mobile wallet
payments yep so i could see why that
would be popular crm data
what are some other
data sources that you're you're using
today
i'll give another minute
but can i mute yourselves too if you
want to even chime in live
crime data transcripts
census
cdc
healthcare
yep somebody is actually using sentiment
analysis on social networks that's great
real estate
student data
so one of the
is a really powerful use case for graph
analysis effectively in community
detection where
if you are able to get transaction data
from any kind of network think of for
example swift the organization that
facilitates international payments
international bank transfers
you actually can understand what are the
key notes and therefore key nexus points
for a financial system and so understand
what are the key risks in a financial
system
what's interesting is that
there was an analysis done by a pro
publica back in 2010 of memory serves
and they were doing a retrospective
on
the financial crisis back in 2007 and
2008 and sort of trying to figure out
well how did it come to be this way
and what they did is collected data from
bloomberg data that was publicly
available to everybody by the way during
the during and leading up to the
financial crisis back in 2008
and
what they did is collected information
on something called cdos or
collateralized debt obligations so those
were basically pools of loans a lot of
them are mortgage loans but there are
all sorts of pools of loans um
car you know car loans
all sorts of different types of loads
and they looked at how
different pools of these cdo's right
different cdos what they owned and what
was remarkable is they showed a web that
showed that all these different cdos
first of all were issued by a handful of
investment banks like 20
and a lot of them owned pieces of each
other so one cdo owns pieces of another
cdo and so on and so you could actually
see clear as day that there was in fact
a network of these collateral debt
obligations such that it took very
little for one cdo to default
before it set off a cascade of defaults
across the collateralized debt market
so such that something like a one
percent change in the value of one
cdo actually could impact trillions of
dollars worth of debt and it had to do a
lot more with the structure of these of
these securities and how they were
priced and who owned them rather than
anything else and so
when i saw that
sitting back at
j.p morgan's desk at the time it became
very obvious that had somebody been
doing this analysis on open data all
along they could actually identify um
choke points in a financial system
identify this type of systemic risk much
much earlier
and so uh i suspect the same types of
opportunities are available today so for
any of you doing analysis in the
financial financial markets um i would
encourage you to have a think about how
you can use a graph analytic framework
in order to understand
uh the financial system better
and demetri before we move on there's
somebody who did ask about the
research paper article that refers to
what you were speaking towards so maybe
um as i'm presenting if you could see if
you could find that and then post that
in the chat i think that would be
helpful yeah let me see if i can find it
while morov continues with the
presentation
uh all right do you want to kind of take
it away to the next section and then as
if anybody has questions uh don't be shy
absolutely
so thank you so much for for telling us
all about that uh the data that you're
using and
hopefully that's maybe sparked some
ideas about additional data sources that
you can use you know one of the big
trends that we're seeing in finance and
gives demetri alluded to earlier is the
fact that more and more institutions are
focused on becoming data-driven
but a lot of times this term is used um
very in a nebulous way and so one of the
pieces that we've found to be most
helpful is to be able to define a little
bit better what does it actually mean to
be data-driven how do you know if you're
data-driven and how can you identify the
key pieces to work on within the
organization
so the way that we've identified that is
across two different axes we have our
data literacy which is the overall
knowledge as well as the
governance and oversight within an
organization
and then also the data infrastructure
which especially in finances is crucial
to ensure that data is accessible
appropriately
and that it's also stored securely
so
thinking about data infrastructure we've
identified these three pillars
data collection data storage and data
access so in terms of data collection uh
you know i saw a lot of evidence about
the data that folks are using um with
its customer transactions crm data
student data so presumably there's some
collection that happens on a continuous
basis
if not that's definitely something to
look into but even more importantly
making sure that the data is collected
in a way that is
then easy to analyze and to store
is also pretty crucial so if you have a
bunch of data that's disorganized maybe
there's a lot of missing values that
makes it a lot more difficult to pull
insights from it so ensuring that the
data collection that you have is not
only collected in a timely manner but
then also stored well
um
and then stored in in a way that makes
it easy to pull insights from
the second pillar is data storage i
think everyone on this call especially
if you're in the finance industry
understands
a lot of the information that you're
dealing with is personal information
whether that's credit scores spending
histories bank account information
ensuring that your data is stored
securely um
is is paramount to that but at the same
time the third pillar data access
is
also very impactful because
if your teams cannot access the data
that they need to make timely decisions
then that makes it difficult to use
um
and that makes it difficult to use the
the actual data that you've collected
so you know you can start to ask
yourself
the data sources that you're using now
is it easy for you to access is it easy
for your colleagues to access um if you
have these types of questions
you know those types of of questions are
ones you should be asking yourself in
order to make sure that
this is um
this is available to you
and then on the other axis we have data
literacy
and with this
you know one of the biggest challenges
that we see is a communication gap
between the data and the non-data
professionals within an organization
so becoming a more data-driven
organization really starts from the top
and that's in terms of data leadership
do executives actually
champion data utilization i would say
most
do but maybe they don't understand the
resources
that they need to allocate or the the
time they need to give people to better
understand how to use data so if you
have a data champion in your
organization if you have one person who
is helping set that data strategy
then that's a good sign that your
leadership is taking this very seriously
the second pillar that we have under
data literacy is data governance and so
i think especially in finance you
probably have a lot of guidelines
where you can access the data how you
can access the data who can see the data
um
do you have these guidelines somewhere
does everybody have access to them are
people using data in a in a way that's
uniform to them so
making sure that across the organization
people are using data in the same way so
that it's easily accessible to all um
and easily transferable and readable so
something simple um or something
straightforward if you don't have a data
dictionary in place putting one in place
already
can help you
ensure that all of your variables are
defined in the same way which makes it a
lot easier to clean and then to analyze
later
last piece is data knowledge
does your staff do you do your
colleagues know how to ask the right
questions about data do they understand
how to interpret the insights about data
without that it makes it really
difficult to start to become more data
driven and to use data to inform your
insights so you know a lot of ways that
we address this
is specifically about developing you
know programs within organizations to
help them become more data driven and to
drive that continuous culture of
learning so
as i'm going through this maybe you have
some questions um or maybe you've
identified hey what's a key pain point
like maybe there's data that you're
unable to access or maybe you're seeing
that a lot of your colleagues are having
difficulty
asking questions about data you know one
source of data that we see a lot are a
bunch of excel spreadsheets that are
live on somebody's laptop and then the
minute that person leaves those those
excel spreadsheets disappear right
that's something that we refer to as
dark data so this is something that can
be ameliorated with data governance or
data storage
was it something i said
i don't know what happened there but i
so if you are wondering where is all of
this data does all of my data live on
excel on my own laptop maybe start
thinking about how you can transfer that
to a secure um
that's that's maybe that's on a cloud
environment so that others can access it
besides you because that type of data
can be increasingly more important
so talking a little bit about this um
it all starts with us right it all
starts with everybody in the room so how
can you start with data analytics if
you're not already doing this already
make sure you're asking questions about
data ask for metrics make your metrics
specific make it measurable so that
people understand what you're looking
for
and that can help drive the insights
that you find and then the decisions
that you make behind that
for inventory you know we asked what
type of data do you have access to i'm
curious how many of your colleagues know
what type of data you have right so
finding the information that you have
access to maybe you'll discover that you
have
this whole other
database you weren't even aware of maybe
you find out that you're already
collecting data about something you had
questions about in the past so
especially in a lot of large
organizations we find that most people
don't know what's available to them and
that's not just in terms of data that's
also in terms of tools
um you know maybe
your organization already has our studio
enterprise right
and you weren't aware of that so asking
those types of questions can help you
better understand that as well
and then you know for collaborating and
talk to your colleagues what we've seen
uh is when you get a bunch of people in
the room to start talking about the
challenges that they're facing in data
or the data they have access to you'll
see that a lot of you are working on the
same
uh issues and to be able to work
together on that you're you know instead
of doubling the work because you're both
solving individually solving it together
tends to make that work go faster and
you might also see that there are
um other
you know aspects uh and other data
sources that you didn't realize you had
how can you support data literacy so
beyond actions that you're doing
yourself what can you do within an
organization
doing these types of lunch and learns
internally perhaps maybe you'll find
this useful
um
hopefully you do so bringing in other
experts to speak about these trends
speak about how data is being used to
speak about these different types of use
cases to inspire others around you to
start to incorporate data
go to data conferences
setting up training opportunities based
on on skills gaps so where do you want
to improve your skills in the data
spectrum and even planning events such
as data competitions can be a really
nice way to
identify top talent
and then also
encourage others to start to think about
how they can apply data to to their work
these are just some ways maybe you can
start thinking of
i'm going to pause here for a minute
we have two three more slides after this
and then we'll we'll stop for
conversation so
based on you know what demetrius talked
about maybe that helped inspire some
questions for you and then thinking
about how you're using data how your
organization is using data i see we have
some questions before i'm going to save
those until the end but i'm curious
about the questions that you might have
that you want to explore with data
analytics maybe you had one before this
presentation
maybe
you have one now
so how do i see data catalogs being used
in data governance that's a great
question
um honestly
a lot of it starts with a simple
spreadsheet
on a shared drive it can be like a
google drive
or a shared document that gives an
overview of where data can be accessed
and then how people are defining
different data terms and different
metrics so
that's what i've seen most common with
federal agencies right now in the us
there are a lot of agencies that are
releasing their own data governance
guide that are specific to
um the bigger vision and the mission of
how they want to be using data in the
future so it's a little bit less
specific to everyday usage and more
specific to the overall vision
are there any data ontology semantic
maps used for knowledge and catalog
that's a good question
um
i mean in terms of semantic backs you
know there are data dictionaries that
are available
um within r that that are semantic
dictionaries specific to um
sentiment analysis
so that's what i've seen it being used
and um
i don't know if dimitri had any
additional insight on that one
oops i didn't realize i was unmute so
um you're also your your camera's
covered oh sorry about that
so um
i don't know of any sort of general
use case ontologies that were that work
well pervasively there are data models
that can help you organize intelligence
ontologies but at the end of the day
um to the best of my knowledge today
they're really tailored to specific use
cases
and so there are principles around
developing a semantic map or data
ontology
and that's that's a much longer
conversation
but
there isn't sort of a here is how you
organize all knowledge type of approach
much more of how do you define a
threshold for what are the key themes
how are those themes related to sub
themes what specific um what specific
items
sort of is that related to and so on um
a
good tool that we've used for this type
of organization is
graph databases so we've used neo4j a
lot there's a
free distribution there's a paid paid
distribution for production grade
software so if you're doing something
for yourself have a look at neo4j uh
free distribution
um and have a look at the way that it
sort of offers you to catalog data its
relationships and metadata that might be
a nice starting point
thanks dimitri
all right so before we finish up the
presentation this is um an area that we
always like to emphasize both in our
training programs and also in our
presentations which is about the the
ethical use of data um so this is a case
study that maybe some of you know this
was one
that
um was done by target so essentially
about 20 years ago at this point in time
target had a lot of information they're
a huge real uh
a huge retail store in the united states
for those who might not live here um
and they had a large customer base of of
you know data about purchases past
purchases and wanted to start to predict
which of their customers would be
pregnant because they know that when
you know an individual is pregnant they
tend to get more set in their habits and
if they can catch somebody during that
stage they tend to be more loyal
customers
throughout their life
so in order to do that they had their
data scientists sift through about two
to
multiple years of data to better
understand okay which of their customers
became pregnant and then what are the
key factors there um that they can use
to then predict who will become pregnant
so
they they did this analysis and at the
end of this analysis they found some key
indicators included
buying ginger ale to help with nausea
um
stopped buying wine was one of the
factors that had a big correlation
as well as buying prenatal vitamins and
things like that
and based on their predictions of who
would become pregnant they started to
send out targeted flyers
and you'd think this is a great use case
of data analytics and it is a
demonstration of an effective use case
but what ended up happening is they sent
one of these flyers to the parents of a
15 year old who hadn't told them that
she was pregnant
so that became a big case
that happened with a few other families
as well
and it started to bring up the question
of it's one thing to be able to mine
customer data for insights but how can
you make sure you're using it in a way
that doesn't cause harm
doesn't you know have ethical
implications to it
so it's important especially given that
we're in the finance space um to think
about how we're using customer data and
how we need to be mindful of that fact
now interestingly enough what target
ended up doing it's not that they don't
use that data for insights anymore what
happens is that they
start to um
put lawn mowers next to baby cribs so
they just are a little bit more subtle
about how they advertise that in the
future
speaking about ethical considerations
another one that's cropped up especially
in the past few years is about biases
that exist in our current data that
inform our models so again
it's our responsibility to ask these
types of questions um there's one where
it's you know how does the data reflect
the society that we're in today and if
it does perpetuate any stereotypes or
biases how can we build models for
future prediction or for example
granting loans that will
mitigate some of those biases and risks
so that we don't perpetuate that
this is a
difficult question i'm spending a few
minutes on it whereas there's there's a
much larger conversation to be had but
the important point to get across here
is
as
you are building these models as you're
involved in these models make sure to
ask these questions about you know
accounting for biases
before the data is being put into the
model making sure that the model
accounts for that um and understanding
how to mitigate that so that
you can make the best decisions for your
customers um without introducing you
know some biases that might already
exist in the data
last last piece that i'll talk about is
you know we talked a little bit about
data infrastructure dimitri talked about
a few case studies that he's seen but on
the other side there's that data
literacy component of that and this is
an example of how a lot of financial
institutions today are starting to
realize it's not only the infrastructure
they need to have in place but it's also
the appropriate staff with those skills
so we've done a lot of work in in the
finance space with that
one of the use cases specifically is
with discover financial services where
they actually developed a pretty robust
infrastructure and what they realized is
they had a lot of new hires coming in
that maybe had some of the prerequisite
skills um with a good foundation but not
all of the skills that they wanted to um
you know that that they needed in order
to be
effective so we work with them to build
an onboarding program that helped train
them
in r
as well as in other tools including sql
and snowflake so that by the time that
they left
that onboarding process they felt much
more comfortable within the
infrastructure that they had so they
could be much more effective off the bat
we see a lot of this happening and it's
not just the onboarding process but
because hiring is so difficult right now
for data scientists they're a rare breed
and i'd say especially in the finance
industry it can be really difficult a
lot of financial institutions are now
turning to this training aspect whether
they're doing it internally or they're
bringing somebody else in to help
develop that skill set across the
organization
i'll i'll finish up with this question
here um i know that there's some other
questions in the chat in the chat that
are more specific so i can pause here
um
and just say first of all thank you for
for coming to this talk today rachel
thank you for for organizing it um i we
love our studio um especially the
hangouts and we find that you know this
just the community has been really
supportive and lovely so we want to make
sure this is valuable for you
um
and now is your time to ask us questions
i'm going to pause here
i'm going to stop sharing my screen so
thank you so much rob and dimitri
that was great i see a lot of questions
coming into the zoom chat and then we
also have the slido link if you want to
ask questions anonymously there as well
um i did also just i meant to do this in
the beginning and maraud your
presentation reminded me this when you
talked about maybe planning lunch and
learns with other people across your
team
the our studio finance team is is
listening in on as well and they would
be happy to help with this too
and if you ever want to see maybe who
else from your company is using our
studio too
and they're a great resource for that
if you want to just say hello kevin
maybe
hey everybody yeah this is my first time
joining uh great great to see a lot of
you a fantastic job on the presentation
that was really interesting
thank you
thank you i see some questions in the
chat i was gonna dive into those if that
if that's a good time that's perfect yep
so i think rachel the first question was
from you in terms of what kinds of
organizations
uh provide employees with technical
skill development versus expect you to
figure it out on your own so uh it's
tough to paint a paint with a broad
brush uh we work with a number of
financial services organizations that
invest heavily in new employee
onboarding and continuous employee
development you know we work a lot with
discover inter-american development bank
capital one all those organizations and
they'll have robust
new employee and existing employee
training programs i know we had very
robust one back at jp morgan so
um
it's tough for me to say well this type
of organization likes to do this versus
you know not that um
so it's tough to put them in buckets but
i know a lot of organizations do have
great programs
um and based on our experience
those who do not have simil
who do not have something like that in
place
uh are increasingly looking to deploy
those types of programs we're seeing a
lot of interest
and and i'll just add on to what major
was saying where i think almost every
organization that we speak to or work
with has some sort of um online training
component
and that can be really helpful i think
especially for a lot of folks on this
call who maybe already have a foundation
in our python and maybe just need to
skill up in one or two things but we
found that a lot of people who are new
to the space tend to get really
overwhelmed with the amount of
information that there is they're not
quite sure where to start and that's
where
organizations are starting to bring in
something that's a little bit more
um
tailored and a little bit more
structured to help both increase
accountability also develop that
community of sharing and collaboration
um and so doing that kind of in tandem
with one another helps build that robust
learning culture
awesome i can um help read out some of
the questions too and if anyone wants to
jump in and ask their question live um
so rang i i see you asked a great
question in the chat if you want to jump
in
i see you're unmuted but i can't hear
you yet
i can start i'll i'll jump to eugene um
and then oh now we can hear you okay
yeah
so thank you guys it was a brilliant
presentations uh presentation thanks for
that uh yeah so my second question was
around one of the challenges that you
know
we face is
uh
figuring out how best to
have
access into
standardized schema documents like xbrl
and then pulling that into our for you
know some sort of standardized financial
modeling and analysis like do you have
any tips or experience that you could
share there
yeah so
in our experience it's been less about
the domain and more about the approach
right so
um
xbrl is a very useful tool you know to
publish uh financial records data
but when we are then taking those
financial records data and trying to
come up with an analysis it's much more
about
for example a data structure that lends
itself to text analysis right so as i
mentioned neo4j has its own structure
for meta tagging and relating uh data in
non in
non-star schema ways
um if you're looking at graph analysis
it's a different approach if you're
looking at you know classification
algorithms they all have their own sort
of data formats uh that you would need
so unfortunately i we i haven't
encountered anything
specific that sort of is
universal for financial modeling
it's more specific to are you looking
for portfolio analysis you're trying to
you know figure out the sharp ratio for
your portfolio or are you looking for
churn metrics uh or something else so it
tends to be more analysis style specific
but if anybody has seen something i'd
love to i'd love to hear from you
and feel free to put that into the chat
too if you want to weigh in there
um you eugene i see you had a question
as well in the chat um
would you like to jump in and add some
more context on that one
uh sure a neo4j i've used here and there
but my curiosity is more of is there
some sort of rule of thumb when scaling
up neo4j because we all know sort of
graph network type tools have a
scalability problem you know the more
vertices the more edges everything
explodes sort of exponentially so i was
just curious if there's a um
a rule of thumb around number of cpus
amount of ram as your as your network
scales for for sort of making neo4j run
in a you know
malleable way uh not on a cluster yeah
so i am unfortunately not the right
person to ask i need to have our
director of engineering on on the line
for this question but i know he figured
this problem out um last year so um i
can connect you guys afterwards if you
drop me an email
thanks
and just letting everyone know um
that i did put in um
both my my email and dimitri's email in
case your question is an answer you want
to learn more or i think it's eugene's
question you need a more specific answer
um we're happy to connect with the right
person and continue that conversation as
well
awesome thank you mara
gregoire i see you asked a question
around r and python too if you want to
jump in
yes thank you very much for the
presentation mirov in dmitry it was very
interesting and i would have liked to
know because i know python is also
more and more use in the finance
industry and
i would have liked to have your
impression and feelings about how r and
python evolved or are adopting
and also
the second question i asked um what do
you think
are the two or three other main
languages that are entering the finance
data driven analysis please
yeah absolutely so
you're right in that the sort of python
user community has grown somewhat faster
because it's grown on the backs of
software engineers
um rather than for example i started as
an r user and so that's still my my
first love as far as programming
languages go
and i find that for example our syntax
is tends to be simpler than that of
python so if you have a software
engineering background picking up python
can be pretty trivial because you're
already familiar with the notion of data
structures if you are starting from an
excel or sort of vba background then
python might look somewhat foreign and r
is going to be a lot easier for you to
adopt
most people who are in finance actually
start it in some form of spreadsheet
software right
so to them transitioning into r would
actually be easier and in my experience
r is going to give you
just easier faster options for
prototyping proving your point doing the
analysis creating interactive
visualization
standing up a light application with
something like our shiny so
um i'm a huge fan of r uh and that's the
main language in which i program it
uh i don't think that the fact that
there's been such a huge uptake in
python for example precludes another
language like r from being you know just
as widely used and helpful ultimately
i've learned it's about your personal
preference and what gets the job done
faster
those two i think still dominate you
know there are going to be some
languages that come into play when
you're talking about scale systems but i
would attribute them less to finance
like there's nothing about finance and
the structure of a different language
that make them better adapted to to
finance right
but when you're talking about some
scaled applications especially for
transaction processing scala is
obviously important right
um
but that's has to do more due to its um
sort of software engineering and data
piping capabilities rather than because
it's better suited to finance in some
way shape or form
it's in my experience
okay
if i could uh
ask you a bit more on that uh r versus
python i think even for us we get that
get into that situation or question
quite often uh
based on your experience uh
how do you find like
convincing or working with teams where
your
business side are very excel well versed
and they might find are a lot more
palatable but the technology groups then
come in and say okay no we are not very
comfortable with people using r and they
were like
on the software side there's a much
bigger preference for python it's like
working with clients or even within your
organization and like going through this
maze of
what should be
encouraged or discouraged or can you
even have both of them working and what
kind of relationship should there be
between
r and python uh
or between business and technology
people how do you navigate conversations
like those
sure so i would push on the word
comfortable and who is comfortable with
what and who is in the
sort of in their right lane in terms of
being comfortable with what right
software engineering is going to be
responsible for secured scale
code but the finance team is responsible
for the analysis being correct right and
so in my experience well the way that i
see it is if you're
writing a piece of code you better be
confident that it's working correctly
from just a mathematical standpoint
and if the finance team is using r and
is comfortable in r then that has to be
the code that actually runs the
financial analysis now there are lots of
you know ways to call a python an r
routine from python and a python routine
from r so they are interchangeable lots
of hooks around it so it shouldn't be
you know everybody must use one language
or another language there are um lots of
ways to make the two compatible in fact
we do that regularly in our lineup work
right there's a lot of packages that are
just better and are than in python and
frankly vice versa and you should limit
yourself to one or the other
so then you know the conversation is
look if you're writing most of the
workflow in python why can't you call
this our subroutine because our analysis
works in there and if the engineering
team wants to reconfigure the etl
in python well that's their prerogative
you're right they're thinking about the
compute time but there shouldn't be sort
of a debate about
you know do you need to change the
actual mathematical
analysis from one language to another
that doesn't feel like a good use of
time given the interoperability that's
available
sounds good thanks
absolutely
i know we're getting down to the
end of our time here but i don't know if
you have a few minutes to run over robin
dimitri is that okay absolutely okay
awesome
um just scrolling through the questions
i see
davin you had asked a question if you
want to jump in and and ask that live
uh yes that will be fine um
yeah i'm just really curious you talked
a lot about the financial sector having
trouble finding
uh qualified staff
to bring on full time and
what do you see for trends in
that type of analysis being
available for freelance workers or
outside organizations consultants things
like that if you just kind of comment on
that i appreciate it
sure
i don't have any stats to speak about
the trend on freelancing specifically
but generally i try to think about
things from first principles and
when
a
person or a tool does and does not make
sense right so i'll answer this question
kind of the same way that i answered the
r versus python question
there are great use cases for when to
use somebody who's a freelancer
um
you know you're usually paying them on a
per project or an hourly basis and
usually they would be more expensive
than a w-2 employee right
and you can usually get them on board
for that very narrow kind of use case
much faster than a w-2
and so there is a reason to utilize a
freelancer for example or an outsourced
firm
when you need to get something
accomplished really quickly but it's an
in-and-out kind of task if you're
talking about somebody who's a permanent
hire
well there's a legal question about do
you want them to be 10 in iowa or w2
right there's actually it's actually
more of a legal an hr question than a
substance question
and then finally if you have a
capability that's ultimately going to be
core
uh you probably want that to live with
your full stem time staff who kind of
bet their careers or when working with
you for the long run
so you know in my experience where you
whether you're outsourcing or
freelancing it's great to get initiative
going
um to make sure that the capabilities
online quickly but then equally have a
plan to kind of have some some full-time
staff
having said that i don't have a command
of the trend of freelance use but i bet
if you went to someone like upwork they
might have some some data analysis
around that
thank you dmitry
and scrolling through to see some of the
questions we missed um
and emilio i see you had asked one in
the chat too do you want to jump in if
you're still on
so can you hear me
yep
thank you uh i just wanted to know if
you have any preference for learning
esg application usually for like your
applications into creative risk
i know it's a very young
field
still working on progress but i will
appreciate if there is any
art library i can
i can start learning or any other kind
of reference that might be useful
thank you
just to make sure that i understand your
uh the effort i'm using you talking
about sort of sustainability metrics for
relatively esg
yeah exactly more specifically
specifically there's
a big push to
implement climate impact into
loan portfolios right now
uh but it's limited to mortgage
uh i want to know if there's any other
kind of
type of loans that might be
already been modelled or any effort
around that
yeah so
um i could talk on this topic for hours
i'll try to try to keep it short
um
there is a really big push across both
regulators investors and industry
participants
around how to measure
climate exposure climate risk
that is true for both energy producing
assets so infrastructure is a big area
where this applies
and equally loans to companies that have
meaningful climate exposure not just
insurance companies but businesses based
in coastal areas
the the
i know the sec is doing a lot of work
around
the appropriate amount of financial
disclosures that would be required from
regulatory perspective with respect to
esg or you know climate change risk
we wrote a
big white paper form about that topic so
there's no standard framework that i'm
aware of right now
they are all
but there's a lot of research and
they're all generally sector dependent
so you mentioned mortgage certainly
right again for coastal areas uh energy
generation assets that's very much true
for them
um
[Music]
but i'm not aware of a framework that
sort of says here's exactly how to think
about it pervasively
hey thank you very much
thank you dimitri um i'm just checking
through to see if there are any other
questions that i miss so feel free to
jump in if there's one that you asked
earlier and we didn't see
you're seeing a comment from brian about
the fact that most
finance output ends up on excel and
powerpoint so using our markdown
simplifies that task i couldn't agree
with you more we use
very heavy uh we're very heavy users of
our markdown uh in a lot of stuff that
we do from trading to the actuals or
solutions custom solution part of the
projects that we build so i couldn't
agree with you more i'm a huge fan of r
for financial services applications and
i think that there needs to be a sort of
intellectual acknowledgement that there
is
software development and there are good
tools for software development
and there are tools for finance where
you need to get to a analytical resource
result quickly and be able to
communicate that easily with other
decision makers and i find that r is
much better for that second use case so
in my from my standpoint it's not about
what's better or a python right they're
both great tools but they have very
distinct use cases
and they have very underused libraries
for calling the subroutines from each
other and creating interoperability i
think it's much more about that than
what is better
well thank you so much for rob and
dimitri for an awesome presentation and
i'll give up people a few more seconds
if you want to jump in and raise your
hand with other questions
but that was great and it's awesome to
get the community together
i did ask in the chat i'm not sure if
anyone's on from the arm finance
conference team
but i saw that they had a call for
papers out for the conference happening
later this year that i shared in the
chat as well
um but thank you all so much for joining
today and
uh marav and dimitri i'll work on
getting the recording together and if
you have the slides you could send over
to me that would be awesome too and i
could put that with the recording yep
we'll get that to you and thank you so
much for putting together such an
awesome group super interactive lots of
questions which is exactly what we love
hopefully everyone feels like they're
taking away some new information today
um that's really our goal is to just
empower people to to use data better and
however we can help do that we're happy
to
yeah i echo that thank you everybody
marvel thank you very much for the kind
words in the chat um we really
appreciate all of you for for dialing in
and all the really good questions and
the great discussion thank you very much
and of course thank you to the art team
you know to rachel and kevin for
organizing this and welcoming us and
making and putting this whole uh
production together obviously this
wouldn't happen without them so thank
you guys so much